يعتمد نظام الشفاء في كالاري على
نقاط طاقة في الجسم تسمى الغرير
حيث تتقاطع عضلات العظام والأربطة.
يمكن استخدام نفس المعرفة
لتحفيز مارا للشفاء ،
وتسمى هذه التقنية نظرية سيروتشي ،
وكلها تعني ضغط القدم ، وأعتقد أنه
ليس من المستغرب إذا كان الأمر كذلك ، فكم من القوة التي
تقف على الرجل بدلاً من الدفع
ربما تستيقظ الكثير من العضلات
والأربطة  التي لم أكن أعرف أنها بحاجة إلى
تحفيز الاستيقاظ يستخدم أيضًا
لعلاج أمراض أكثر خطورة مثل
الألم المزمن والأمراض العصبية والعضلية ،
كما تعلم ، لقد تساءلت دائمًا عن
هذه الأنواع من العلاجات التي كانوا موجودون
بها منذ فترة طويلة.
شيئًا ما
لماذا يستمر شيء ما لمئات
السنين وربما لآلاف السنين ، فهو
يعتقد فقط أن هناك شيئًا ما تحت
أمعائي
[موسيقى]
تعلمون أم  ضربت قليلا
انتهكتني أشعر أنني كومة كبيرة
من جيلو الآن